[Music]
okay so we've taken back a lot of the
stuff with government we've taken back
all of those things do you think that's
actually possible like is that is the
government too big at this point and are
people too dumb down to understand why
big government isn't important so for
example when I hear a lot of
progressives saying you know that just
the government should redistribute and
all of these government programs and
they get upset when we cut money to the
arts I don't think that's going to stop
art I think it actually might help art
that but we've just become so numb to
how things work that if you were to try
to reverse some of this stuff you might
do some really irreparable damage in
ways that maybe we can't even see well
the risk of sounding like a founding
father quote so TJ I brought the wigs
and I'm tired of it I edited the natural
tendencies for government to grow in
Liberty to shrink so do I think we can
go back I think we can the only problem
is is that we have to adopt not not the
principles but the tactics of some of
our opponents so I have to Fabian
socialists who want to try and grow
government bit by bit is we're going to
have to try and fight a war a game of
inches right and we're going to have to
take ground bit by bit so I do think
that we can go back but the problem is
is that with with my movement the
Liberty movement is that we're not
content with small gains right we want
to see big games we want to start seeing
major victories because we see our
opponents getting major victories all
the time and I think we've got to be a
little bit more patient we've got to
fight you know on the the short game
before we can worry about the long game
in some ways why doesn't the party do
anything down ticket why is it that you
only hear about libertarians come
national election time and as far as I
know there's are there any there there
must be some randomly about libertarians
in go there it's just that we sort of
there's not a lot of incentives because
when you run as like a senator or for
president as a libertarian you're you're
going to get the same amount of Hell
that you're going to get if you run for
lower office but at least there's the
benefit of getting a little bit of
notoriety right a little bit of the same
perhaps a little bit of opportunity to
advance your ideas I mean when you're
running for the for the
dog catchers a libertarian you're going
to get the same amount of hell but it's
your neighbor next door that's going to
give it to you so I think that the
incentives are probably wrong
you know messed up there and also we
just I think there's a salon people
don't know what it means to be a
libertarian a lot of people who will you
know Bill Maher says he's a libertarian
and what's the guy the John Bolton
Ambassador John Bolton came on my show
once and was like I'm a libertarian
really invade Russia because I think of
it more as a neocon right well to some
neocon so this is going to make more
people angry to some neo-cons they
actually consider themselves anarchists
in a sense no borders right and that if
we see somebody if we see somebody like
a genocide going on overseas and things
like that well if we believe in a
borderless world and these are all
humans members of the human race why
should we not intervene overseas I mean
a lot of Democrats agree with that right
that we should be stepping into Darfur
and Sudan and Yemen and we should be you
know having humanitarian interventions
around the world and so the
neoconservatives in some ways think of
themselves as libertarian humanitarians
in it in some way because by bringing
democracy to the Middle East they they
are spreading freedom around the world
and that's they're thawed the problem is
is that you buy in using government for
this you know they they're their ends
may be positive but the means that they
that they use end up you know what's the
destruction of regimes and with
humanitarian crises right so what would
your position be on that then I know
that obviously you wouldn't be pro
nation-building but in the case of a
true genocide or a case of what's
happening in Syria now I think the
general libertarian idea is thought of
as isolationist where do you fall in
some sense the the some of returns are
isolation is actually may that that's
more of a paleo conservative thing
people who want to build a wall in
southern border right and they want to
stop trade overseas those are those
people are much more isolationist but
there are ways to solve these problems
and if you're going to use government to
solve foreign policy problems you should
use the Constitution that's really what
it is and and the problem is is that we
ignore the Constitution the Constitution
actually gives and and libertarians
don't talk this up in
the Constitution does give the Congress
some authorization to act in a manner
that would make liberals very angry
which is that it would allow the
Congress to lay a letter of marque and
reprisal the last time they did that was
the war of 1812 so international laws
and norms have changed so if it's a if
it's a terrorist activity essentially it
would be something similar to how you
are we dealt with Osama bin Laden
because we have such a deep and profound
sense of patriotism United States we
think only the government can kill
terrorists we're not willing to get you
know go all 1776 on that and hire a merc
which really what we're talking about
here so in a case like that like in a
bin Laden type case you would actually
be for that you hire you're basically
subcontract contracting our army out and
it's probably you would argue I assume B
would be a cheaper and more effective
way right I'll do it Ron Paul after 9/11
actually introduced legislation to to go
and to kill bin Laden using letters of
marque and reprisal because at least
worth following constitutional due
process 'as a lot of libertarians that
that don't agree with the authorization
for the use of military force have to
admit that that was quote-unquote a
congressional authorization and and the
real problem that we that we're dealing
with in terms of laws the laws of war
are that if we declare war on Isis in
some sense if we lose we're legitimizing
them as a state actor in some ways we
don't want to do that so in order for us
to behave in a manner that that is in
conduct with constitutional principles
reviving article 1 section 8 in the
letters of Mark is a way for us to
follow constitutional processes but the
problem is is that liberals aren't going
to like this because if we're talking
about privatizing the military and
conservatives aren't going to like it
because it's not the whole badass Team
America hey laughter 19:6 kill them
right but we have we've got a thousands
of former veterans who are out of work
would love to do the United States a
favor yeah and if you gave them a
contract one of the beautiful things
about it is only libertarian is going to
like this is that any bounty that they
capture over there can be brought back
and sold to the United States so all
those guns that fell into the hands of
Isis can come back and be sold not in
California but very where I'm from we
could have a beautiful
you know military grade weapon so when I
hear you talk about this I can go there
intellectually with you for sure and I
like the ideas and especially if you
route things in the Constitution I love
that yeah when I hear you say this oh
there's a piece of me going this sounds
like Rambo or you know it just sounds
like some 80s movies a short later or
salon where they got a bunch of
mercenary I'm pretty sure this was a
movie but just partly the rock right
right they got a bunch of disgruntled
former military men they come together
they find the guy I think predator was
sort of about this - there's an alien
that you're going to write a bit yes but
but the idea of that that just sounds
crazy to people I'm not saying are you
it's crazy but just so how do you even
know I dare then well new ideas are all
they always sound crazy right like
legalizing marijuana thirty forty years
ago you're crazy you're stupid you're
stoner bubble blah and now we see the
things start to change right and you
know crazy people like the the problem
with this is is that is that there's
this really great quote would somebody
use the other day on Twitter they said
that smart people sound like crazy
people - stupid people so so the problem
may not be that just because of an
opinion is in the minority that's wrong
right most of the time whenever people
like oh you're on Digg is crazy nobody
agrees with you well you know maybe most
people are kind of stupid
yeah so maybe you're the crazy one yeah
and the media is not helping that no I
know at some point you've got to be
willing to put your foot in the ground
and take a stand and say I don't care if
nobody agrees with me I'm going to take
a stand on principle and listen the
founding fathers did not put this into
the Constitution for no reason you know
why they did this it's because the war
of 1776 was primarily won on the Seas by
private Mariners there was no
Continental Navy there was something
like maybe six or seven ships there were
over a thousand who people who turn
their merchant mariner ships into dogs
of war I mean this is the days of
fighting sail but I mean it without
those merchant mariners turned
privateers we would not have won our war
of independence they captured hundreds
of British ships so I mean when it when
the going gets tough sometimes you have
to turn the private market to solve
these things but again the reason why is
distasteful to the establishment is for
two different reasons
love it they're like oh this is a great
idea but we'll never get the liberals on
board and we'd much rather trust it to
our Navy Navy SEAL team guys and the
Liberals are like oh my god you're
privatizing war I mean you know it's
horrible if the free market and it's war
and that it's very hard to win that
battle but I mean whatever I do I try
and couch it in actual precedent law the
law of the Constitution that way I think
you remain consistent and you know again
new ideas are always sound crazy until
they finally become accepted yeah so
speaking of precedent and the
Constitution what do you think of the
general state of the Constitution right
now I think it's a pretty beautiful
almost perfect document to be governed
by but it doesn't seem to be what we're
really governed by anymore it's being
trampled in every direction right now
you know you can make cases that Trump's
trampling it in certain ways with
executive actions and by the way Obama
did plenty of them in george w bush did
plenums that's a nonpartisan write
attack we also don't you know we do
military actions where we don't get
congressional authorization what was
Libya a yeah what they call it a kinetic
military action is right they just make
up terms and you go oh that's not a war
right I'm pretty sure if Libya had been
blowing us apart we call it a war yeah
so the general state of how we are are
or not covered by the Constitution in
many ways I think we're living in a post
constitutional republic you know it has
some of the trappings of a
constitutional republic and you know the
good thing is is that the Bill of Rights
still exists it's still in force I mean
Congress uses the Fifth Amendment all
the time and I know they've got people
in there in the hearings that are always
having to plead the fifth yeah that's a
big one right and then they of course
the count the Supreme Court relies on
the Second Amendment when it upholds
decisions and like Heller or or McDonald
vs Chicago so you've got the Second
Amendment I don't think anybody well
maybe some people would like to get rid
of it but yeah there's my yeah sure but
but most people I think you know cooler
heads will prevail on that issue you've
got the First Amendment which is in
retreat in a lot of ways college
campuses probably primarily the spots
where they're in retreat and you know it
also retreat in some ways in the
mainstream media this is why you know
the Rubin report is probably so popular
and successful not just because you're
so tremendously talented but because but
because people are seeking out ultra
naté
means of information you know we don't
live in in North Korea so I can't say
that the Constitution has been a total
failure but I do think that in some ways
the Constitution was far from perfect
the founders tried to get rid of slavery
at the signing of the Declaration of
Independence it didn't happen it took
you know another hundred years in a
bloody civil war so so there were some
institutional problems with the the
Constitution and we've had we had to
pass the 13th and a 14th amendment yeah
and again it took a war for that but I
think that you know if you look at
post-war amendments you of course you've
got things like you've got the 16th and
17th amendments which have been you know
the most anti libertarian parts of the
Constitution
now we have a law by bureaucracy right
so so many and many times with things
like the FDA or the EPA they'll they'll
write law and enforce it and that was
that was definitely alien to the concept
of constitutional laws written by the
founders and so with with if you're
going to have a bureaucracy then I think
the bureaucracy should be limited to
operating within constitutional law but
if they're going to going to you know
create laws and those laws should have
to be passed by Congress and they those
laws are regulations in many ways yeah
so that's really where the problem comes
is with all the executive branch
agencies that have been created that are
that I think are probably the biggest
problem that we have yeah for the record
I didn't mean that that in and of itself
it's perfect but in terms of the way
that we can be governed as we humans or
the ones that writers have yeah it's
pretty close the best yeah I've got
because we've got us in it and we are
flawed things that create these things
so as perfect as maybe we can create but
according to just as a independently the
biggest thing though is that for some
reason the founders didn't build a wall
on the southern border so that can be
improved upon well because at the time
there there would have been no need for
a casino big boy all right so you
mentioned an EPA so the two ones that I
hear all the time or the fruit of drug
administration these are the two that
you hear right when people say
libertarians are nuts even Bill Maher
who I know he hath now identifies his
libertarian but he's for a lot of big
government stuff at the same time you
know I saw a couple weeks ago he said
something about the Trump you know got
rid of this thing with the EPA
and now they're going to start dumping
in rivers again is immediately what he
said and to me it's like we now live in
2017 where everyone has a phone and if
the company of block away from these
dumping in the river or smokes coming
out of their chimney or that everyone
would report on everyone that's another
problem that society has altogether
right but that we would police ourselves
in a way and as john stossel who i love
would always say you know the more
regulations we keep putting in company
just figure out other ways to do it we
just keep putting money in lawyers
pockets and we're not actually
accomplishing anything we're just
shifting around makes writing
all over the place
so I I jump down yeah go ahead right so
so two things there's an EPA and then
there's the FDA so very briefly with the
EPA the EPA was created by Nixon it was
created to essentially offer scientific
information and court cases where a
property rights are in dispute so the
original idea behind the EPA is a good
one because you know Congress is is not
made up entirely of scientists right
it's mostly lawyers and lawyers aren't
environmental scientists and so you're
going to need the testimony of
environmental scientist is going to need
someone to actually go out and do the
research clean up find the samples and
prove perhaps that some company is
putting too much mercury or some sort of
toxin into the into the environment
you're gonna need science for that
specifically not be political though
right not be a political right and not
to be the enforcement arm right because
right now they're a bunch of unelected
bureaucrats with assault rifles
you've got to EP I think the US
Department of Agriculture has submachine
guns right that right yeah so what are
they doing we're gonna chicken the cows
you know that's not but there's a when
it comes to the yep yeah I actually
think the FDA is an easier case to make
for the case of abolishment because even
though people they think oh my gosh
floats the things that we eat all the
time I'm like yeah actually and you
haven't noticed people are much more
conscious about what they eat and you
know whenever I look at Yelp for reviews
perfect example every time you don't eat
somewhere I go any somewhere if I've
never been there before I check the
upper yeah if they're like it's dirty
it's got cockroaches you know terrible
service I don't go there and and that
that's a market mechanism that's a
regulation right it's a free market
regulation that people use in order to
determine whether or not they should eat
somewhere I mean it doesn't take very
long to figure out
that you know some some food source is
bad but the problem is is that what
anybody makes a mistake which they do
even the government can't even stop
right so in Salmonella from getting out
it happens whenever somebody's child
dies you know then they say well one
death is too many let's create an
enormous government institution for the
children and we'll save all the kiddies
and if you don't do this then you hate
children and you want all the children
to die and that's why we have these
institutions because of the politician
it's so much easier to say well I'm for
the children I'm for checking children's
food and we don't want them putting
poison in babies milk right because yeah
because people really have an incentive
to poison graves milk right because
actually if you are a good producer of
food and you create clean healthy food
you make more money you make more Whole
Foods they're making much more than the
the lower end retail chains so I just
walk in there and hand them all my cash
yes I'm like I know I'm not walking out
of here with any money well so it in
some sense it's elitism because because
what they'll do is like the people who
argue for it will say oh well I'm not
worried about me right I mean I can
unlock my fee like I have no problem
with it like if I had a private agency
that was you know checking the food and
had to stamp on it I would be fine but
it's all the underclass right it's the
plebs that we need someone to take care
of them right it becomes a very elitist
thing that we need to have the
government because we need to have the
really really smart people like about it
100 or you know two to two or three
hundred of them sitting sitting room
making these decisions for the pleads
you know and that's and that's what it
comes down to there eternalists
you know I never thought of it in the
whole foods concept but there is
something really there because you know
if you go to Whole Foods at least the
one over here they've got you know five
levels of how they treat the animal and
want it you know the lowest is like free
range which is still pretty damn good
the highest it's like they took them out
to dinner before and they drugged them
and yeah whatever that sounded weird but
well the point is that that's all done
by whole food right it's by their policy
right but what if they don't do it at
Walmart you see the good and then the
paternalistic extent is like but they
don't do that at Walmart well you don't
shop at Walmart well well but but other
people do and I care about them no you
don't you don't care about them you're
not charitable because you go and you
take a gun and you put it to somebody's
head and you say you will make sure this
food is clean yeah but is there any
evidence of
I swear that was scale-like before the
FDA existed were there a lot of stores
that were accident think people are
intentionally poisoning Tomatoes you
know a little grosser but is there any
evidence that that it actually
accomplished anything yeah I mean there
the thing is is that it's all about the
incentives right so the question is is
do you think that people are
incentivized to actually do good by the
community because the way the capitalism
works is the better you serve your
community the more they the more money
you make
yeah right but but yeah they're there
and there's always examples of you know
just like there have been financial
panics before the Federal Reserve but
somehow instead of having great you know
instead of having great depressions like
we did post fed we have these little
short-term blips little panics that
happen in a year it cleans itself out
and it's gone but now what we do is
government steps in and it prolongs
crisis right exacerbates crisis because
then you have to have taxpayer money
spent on the cleanup right whereas
before if there was like a food
poisoning case right a local judge would
have a judgment and they would they
would exact you know tribute and they
would bring it back to you know whatever
the the victims were you know and there
would be just compensation for that but
again it comes down to the question of
whether or not you think that some you
know bureaucracy in Washington DC can
centrally plan all the food and all of
the drugs right everybody takes in the
United States
I think it's hubris to assume that a
that people are smart right and yeah you
can get the best people in the world you
know and put them in a little room and
hopefully you're going to get some good
ideas but but more often than not it's
again it's hubris because they think
that they can possibly plan all of our
lives they can't
yeah the definition of socialism is
central planning like central control
over our lives right ninety percent
income tax rate you have no choice the
state plans everything and that's really
the road to serfdom no actually right
it's it's a date freedom is dangerous
freedom if dangerous as hell yeah but
I'll tell her to start poisoning our
Tomatoes yeah and by the way you know
with all this inspector stuff of course
for stuff you can pay off an inspector
very easily sure there's so many little
ways around it it reminds me a little
bit like when I was a kid yeah
went to sleepaway camp and the day and
the camp would be like a disaster for
three weeks and they're like swimming in
sewage
the day before visiting day when the
parents are coming they clean up the
whole frickin page and it looks good
parents come they're happy and then they
leave next thing you know next day we
have lice and we write well those others
dead right but the difference between a
private inspector and a state inspector
is that if the both those have a
tendency to be corrupt but you can't
find a state inspector right it's going
to take an election or it's going to
take you know some connections in DC
right but if you've got a private
inspector then they are much they're
much more tied to their communities and
and again you can fire them you can
prosecute them and the government will
will guarantee you is going to step in
and clamp down on that but if it's the
government and you're trying to sue the
state it's very difficult
[Music]
you